welcome to Primal 101 with molecular
memory
in this lesson we'll explore the less
active confirmation of
phosphofructokinase bound to an
inhibitor
we'll use the inhibitor to generate a
binding site instead of selecting
residues given to us in a manuscript
like we did in lesson two
this is helpful when we may not have
access to an article load the biological
assembly of 6 pfk in pymol
file
get pdb
6pfk assembly one
then color by chain with CPK coloring
and display the sequence
scroll until you see the three letter
codes for the inhibitor molecules
notice the PGA ligands have taken on the
color of a chain that they're close to
we'll model the interactions of just one
of the ligands let's select the cyan PGA
this light blue green one here the
letters s-e-l-e pop up
in lesson 2 we learn to rename
selections to save them
a rename
delete the letters s-e-l-e that come up
in the upper left of the structure
viewer window
type inhibitor and press enter
now I'll click in the blank space to
make sure I don't add anything unwanted
to this selection
let's zoom in on the inhibitor
a zoom I'll use the pinch motion on my
trackpad to zoom out a bit if you're
using a mouse right click will Zoom
there's too much clipping to really see
The Binding site so I'll adjust that by
running two fingers up and down on the
track pad now we can see the inhibitor
is actually binding between two chains
of the protein
if we want to focus on just the parts of
the structure the ligand is interacting
with we can hide the other chains
this isn't 100 necessary here but I
really want to show you some of the
options in the mouse control menu click
where it says selecting residues and the
menu changes
let's stop on chains click on the
inhibitor and the two chains in the
structure viewer
you can also select by clicking in the
sequence display menu
zoom out a bit and then next to s-e-l-e
hide unselected now we're going to copy
the inhibitor selection and modify it
inhibitor a duplicate
a new selection
sclo1 pops up
we'll turn this into the binding site so
let's rename it binding to select nearby
residues a modify around
residues within four angstroms to
capture all hydrogen bonding amino acids
if you choose a 5 angstrom sphere
that'll capture residues that may be
interacting through Van Der waals
interactions too
now show sticks
and zoom in on The Binding site
to select binding site water molecules
only we can modify The Binding site
selection we just made
duplicate the selection called binding
rename
selo2 to Active water
now action button modify
restrict to solvent
and let's show these as spheres time for
some adjustments the water spheres are
large and obscuring the active site
resize them using a preset a preset ball
and stick the Inhibitors cyan carbons
are blending in with some of the binding
site residues let's recolor them
C by element and I'll select this one
with white carbons
now to add some interactions
inhibitor a button find
polar contacts
are a bunch of choices here but let's
just choose to any atoms
and we can indeed see interactions with
both protein chains
if we'd like we can change the line
color let's try magenta
and as we're getting closer to a
publication quality image let's go ahead
and change the background to White
display drop down background
White
if we want to remove the nearby residues
that aren't making polar contacts we can
even though they're close enough to have
Van Der waals interactions with the
ligand first we need to change our Mouse
control menu back to the default
residues click here in the mouse control
menu until it reads residues
now click on binding in the names panel
carefully deselect any residues that
don't have dotted lines going to them by
clicking on them you'll need to rotate
and zoom while doing this
and if you accidentally deselect
something you didn't mean to just click
on it again to add it back
okay I think everything's still selected
has polar interactions now
way to show our modified binding site is
to hide all the sticks then add back the
inhibitor and modified active site
first 6pfk hide sticks
now let's add the hydrogen bonding
residues back inhibitor show sticks
binding show sticks
finally click in the blank space to
deselect everything
notice this arginine is interacting
through its side chain but we're showing
the entire residue with its backbone
atoms
we can clean this up a bit more by just
showing the side chain
and we can do this one or two residues
at a time without saving the selection
click on the appropriate residues
s-e-l-e hide main chain
looking good we can delete this
selection if we want now
we want someone looking at our image to
be able to easily interpret it let's
label the amino acid residues of The
Binding site
binding L residues okay there they are
but some are super hard to see
we're going to move them using edit mode
to start I remove all clipping and find
a relatively unobscured view of The
Binding site where all of the residues
can be seen clearly
now Zoom The Binding site to let Primal
add its own clipping back
now you need to save your session this
is an essential save point
you can completely mess up the protein
in edit mode and you can't undo it so
take a moment to save your Primal PSE
session file Ctrl save in the mouse
control menu the mouse mode can be
changed from viewing to an editing mode
by clicking
now if I press command on my Mac
keyboard and click and drag on the
labels I can reposition them
but if you accidentally click the
protein you can move it completely
messing up the structure
so I encourage you to save after each
and every label move
awesome job that's a ton of work
first click on the mouse control menu to
exit edit mode
now save a scene of your hard work
in the drop down menus
scene store F1
right click on the scene and rename it
it's really tricky to show an active
site without a protein Loop getting in
the way or some poor looking clipping
to be honest I sometimes completely hide
the amino acid residues in a loop that's
getting in the way I really like the
context the cartoon gives but another
strategy is to hide the cartoon
completely
6 pfk h cartoon
now we can remove clipping completely
and the active site residues just seem
to float there
let's save a scene
now you can toggle back and forth and
choose which scene you prefer or try to
modify further thanks for watching this
episode of pymol 101 next time we'll
learn about the measurement wizard if
you're enjoying this series please
subscribe to my channel